The Boeing Company proposes a personal
transportation system or pts which
provides point-to-point transportation
for individuals using a number of taxi
like personal aerial vehicles
our goal in model-based embedded in
robotic systems is to have humans and
robots collaborate together to achieve
high-level goals defined by human
operators we demonstrate the capability
of our architecture on a personal
transportation system scenario where the
personal aerial vehicle takes off from
Provincetown and heads to Bedford on the
way there are multiple nearby airports
and each Airport has a no-fly zone that
must be avoided the user inputs the trip
specification by highlighting start goal
alternative landing sites and no-fly
zones using the graphical user interface
the pike module calculates the
corresponding visibility graph and the
shortest path from the start to the goal
if the remaining fuel capacity is not
sufficient Pike generates the path to
the closest alternative landing site the
generated path is communicated to Sulu
and the users through the graphical
interface here the GUI updates the
real-time location of the plane while in
the corner is a flight simulation using
X plane a personal aerial vehicle takes
off from Provincetown Municipal Airport
the architecture automatically navigates
the vehicle to the user specified
destination the system is also capable
of adapting to a changing environment
for example if a storm approaches the
vehicle it will automatically replan the
path to avoid the storm
of course the replanned path respects
all the no-fly zones the system keeps
updating the plan based on the current
best available information this
demonstration shows the capabilities of
our autonomous system in providing safe
and optimal paths in a dynamic
environment